para esta mujer española que desea
permanecer en el anonimato abortar fue
una pesadilla hace unos años vivió en
las islas canarias en lanzarote en esta
isla de 150.000 habitantes no hay
instalaciones que realicen abortos
para que yo me tenía que personar en una
clínica de otra isla de la isla de gran
canaria
porque se ve que el lanzarote no se
podía no digo nada por eso para que no
se para que no se penalice en el trabajo
el resumen y por eso hoy en día de mis
vacaciones
esta es una situación común en las islas
canarias pero también en toda españa' de
las 50 provincias del país en 11 de
ellas no se realizaron abortos un
desequilibrio territorial del que ha
sido víctima
te sientes como si te estuvieran tomando
el pelo realmente ese derecho al aborto
seguro legal y gratuito se debería
garantizar en cada sitio donde hubiera
un centro de salud y una persona tiene
problemas de acceso a un derecho en los
ingresos en privilegios
sólo el 15 de los abortos se realizan en
centros públicos la razón es que la gran
mayoría de los médicos acogen la
cláusula de conciencia para no realizar
abortos en esta manifestación provida
defienden esta objeción
durante la gente y si está haciendo
es
fundamental la libertad de creencia en
la medicina pública y muchos médicos que
no creen que deban ir en contra de la
vida del no nacido
[Aplausos]
el gobierno socialista está estudiando
la posibilidad de crear una lista de
escritores de conciencia el reto es
conseguir que haya suficientes médicos
para garantizar el derecho al aborto en
toda españa' una lista denunciada por
los médicos estudiantes presentes en su
mayoría ángeles cuando se hablaron de la
mayoría de los profesionales sanitarios
no analistas de objetores por que
agotarán la tinta
[Aplausos]
las 200 clínicas privadas subvencionadas
realizan el 85 por ciento de los abortos
esta estructura fue la primera en
realizar estas intervenciones en españa
a la fecha de la última regla cuando ha
sido
sonia lamas trabaja allí como psicóloga
según ella la formación médica que se
imparte para realizar abortos no es
suficiente esta formación es obligatoria
por ley sabemos que ninguna comunidad
autónoma en españa está llevando a cabo
formar a sus profesionales y ahora mismo
en españa nos encontramos con un
problema de relevo generacional
critica el estigmatización de los
profesionales del sector
el día que decida ya no trabajar más en
este área mi currículum va a tendrá una
mancha trabajar en la práctica del
aborto estigmatiza otra de las luchas de
señalamos es la de combatir en los
grupos antiabortistas que periódicamente
hacen campaña frente a la clínica
entre ellos 40 días por la vida durante
la cuaresma estos católicos se reúnen
frente al edificio con carteles en mano
mercedes abad viene siempre que puede
santamaría madre de dios en ruega por
nosotros pecadores ni venimos a acosar
ni venimos a hablar con los empleados
del centro ni venimos a hablar con las
madres ni con la gente que les va a
acompañar sólo venimos a rezar porque la
oración es el arma más poderosa que
tenemos
este movimiento está activo en muchas
ciudades al final de su movilización los
voluntarios están satisfechos con sus
resultados
vayamos salvado gracias a dios 8 vidas
con sus respectivas madres
en el congreso la mayoría parlamentaria
quiere que este tipo de acciones de
castigo un delito de acoso sea redactado
un proyecto de ley pero para esta joven
activista sería una injusticia
atenta contra muchísimos derechos como
el derecho de libertad de expresión de
reunión libertad religiosa o rezar no se
puede no se nos puede meter en la cárcel
ni vender multas el proyecto de ley fue
indicado por este miembro de la mayoría
socialista está haciendo campaña para
que se incluyen en el código penal las
sanciones por acoso frente a las
clínicas
será castigado con la pena de prisión de
tres meses a un año
de trabajo en beneficio de la comunidad
un texto que ha sido fuente de tensión
en el parlamento durante los debates
ofrecen ustedes cuanto quieran pero
dejen a las mujeres ejercer sus derechos
un segundo señoría durante esta sesión
es interrumpida por un miembro del
partido de extrema derecha foxx obstina
el acuerdo continúa el señor a ver una
escena que le anima a continuar su lucha
contra los grupos project tales clientes
se intenta impedir que las mujeres
accedan a una prestación sanitaria
reconocida en la cartera de servicios de
la sanidad pública española por lo tanto
se acosa a las mujeres que van a la edad
y sobre la bancada socialista en el
congreso espera que esta ley penal puede
ser aprobada ya este aire un obstáculo
menos para el aborto de las mujeres
exponentes
[Aplausos]